first of all you got to break up with
your boyfriend Donald Trump who would
you say is more authentic him or Joe
Biden him he's more authentic him or
Elizabeth Warren but authentic does it
mean good if you're authentically a
crazy person pretty good when he was
president what was pretty good we
weren't in a recession the Border was a
little bit better we didn't have a crazy
war in Ukraine like he hasn't conceded
the election for four years when he was
president Hillary Clinton he's an
illegitimate president he didn't say
that yes she did I met him and I I kind
of was like all right he's not evil he's
not Hitler and he's certainly not a
homophobe they used to have these Trump
rallies on Sundays they didn't burn down
Rodeo Drive like black lives matter and
I'm telling you you could have walked in
that audience yes would a certain amount
of people have been like I [ __ ] Bill
Maher and but but you know what a lot of
people would have been there like you
know what Bill Maher's here that's
pretty cool think how different that
would be than if you went to an AOC
rally where you would be hated Beyond
imagination you're right it's just true
it's just they're they're the left are
more purists